speaking of Donald Trump in immigration
I do want to talk about this heavily
heavily hyped speech that Donald Trump
did yesterday to try to clear up the
multiple flip flip flip flip flip flops
about what is going to happen with his
immigration policy Trump started his
campaign very strongly with an
aggressive policy on undocumented
immigrants which was deport all 11
million of them by force and build a
wall with Mexico that they will pay for
then it softened a little bit too well
we're going to deport the violent
criminals we're gonna have some empathy
everything sort of negotiable and this
started a conversation of wow it seems
like Donald Trump is actually kind of
moving to what the president obama
policy has been which was as has been a
significant number of deportations but
we're taking into consideration people
situations we're taking into
consideration the fact that there are
families now uh where the children were
born here to undocumented immigrant
parents and we're not gonna break up
those families at this point and then it
looked like that backfired so we seem to
go back to deport them all okay Trump
then says I'm giving a speech on
Wednesday and i will tell you more and i
will tell you the actual plan will the
speech happened and i guess in a way
nothing happened that the deportation
seems to be on Trump said you cannot
obtain legal status period or become a
citizen of the United States by
illegally entering our country and
promised that if he is the next
president gangs would disappear
completely impossible promise will never
happen and that illegal immigration
would decrease and safety would be
increased for all saying we will
terminate the Obama administration's
deadly and it is deadly non enforcement
policies that allow thousands of
criminal aliens to freely walk our
streets do whatever they want to do
crime all over the place that's over
that's over folks that's over uh so what
is the policy here I mean I guess it's
the same thing that President Obama has
doing it has been doing just more
strongly enforced in some way I think so
but it's interesting because in this
case of him kind of waffling back and
forth he's not even really being kind of
cited as a waffler and it's interesting
if you look at John Kerry
who is kind of considered the original
waffler who only waffled when
circumstances changed about the Iraq war
and then on on immigration nothing here
is changed yet he's going back and forth
clearly just a pander to to voters well
this is up this illuminates the total
vacancy of the Swift Boat movement that
successfully branded John Kerry is a
flip flopper back uh in 2004 where John
Kerry after circumstances did change you
know that the famous quote I was for it
by was against that before I was for it
I was for but before I was against it
whatever it was up branding him as as a
flip flopper and that really stuck with
him throughout the campaign Jason here
we have Donald Trump who for no reason
whatsoever other than the PR and
political posturing purposes has taken
somewhere between three to six different
positions on immigration five to ten
different positions on what if anything
the federal minimum wage should be all
sorts of different positions on a bunch
of different issues and although now
independent media is saying hey on this
issue he is a flip-flopper he's mostly
evaded that critique when it's far worse
you know I really like waffles but I
prefer for breakfast I don't want them
in my my presidential office there is
some practicality maybe Rachel to that
Donald Trump floated this idea of being
a little more empathetic on the
deportation and then because his bases
mostly so extreme they said wait wait
wait a second empathy what are you
talking about Donald no no no and then
he had to back up and say now I'm back
on the deportation but with these this
proves to me Trump doesn't really have
anything that is his personally held
belief on almost every issue I'm
increasingly convinced by these taking
every single position on so many issues
that it's just kind of like well what
should I say what's gonna win votes Oh a
sure i'll say a 0 the opposite of a
let's try that oh it doesn't work i'll
go back to a because his personal
convictions are essentially non-existent
in this relates number one to the
reality that historically he's been more
of a left voter than
right voter but also he just doesn't
know very much about politics right
exactly and I think because he also
tends to kind of circle around what he's
saying and if he doesn't really have any
core principles and I guess you're kind
of kryptonite of saying okay he's a
waffler it's not gonna affect him as
strongly because he's not going bouncing
back and forth as much from A to B it's
kind of a wash of ABC and D and not only
is it not going to hurt him we talked
earlier this week about how Trump voters
have been interviewed and they've been
asked aren't you worried that his policy
ideas are either one sentence with no
explanation whatsoever or taking three
four or five completely conflicting
positions on issues doesn't that concern
you and many Trump boaters remember
Jason we had a quote from someone who
spoke to NPR said I consider what Trump
says more of us a starting point I don't
really think that that it's all going to
be figured out now he'll figure it out
I'm comfortable with what he says just
sort of being a starting point nothing
is really set in stone and I mean that
is a hell of an understatement yeah he's
using this is a giant just testing
ground a life of you know spewing verbs
and words out together and hoping that
one second the population takes to this
one one second population takes this one
and somehow everyone's gonna be happy
and vote for its absolute idiocy but
it's working it's a it's actually making
many people say I kinda like it you know
because find his positions in january
march april in june on immigration they
don't really appeal to me his februari
position on immigration i really think
that that's a guy could vote for and of
course this is because the guy stands
for absolutely nothing other than trying
to finagle away to get into the white
house which it's possible that he would
do and we'll talk about the updated
polling we have early next week let's
take a break there is a lot coming up
today I'm glad you're with us I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it
includes gas you just pay for the time
that you actually use the car and you
can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zipcard each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1,600
pounds per year for our audience zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com /
David support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at join zipcar dot-com /
David